ساعات تطور لافت في موقف الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل
ابرزه الاجتماع الطارئ للهيئه الاداريه
ثاني اعلى سلطه في الاتحاد
الاجتماع جاء على خلفيه اعتقال مسؤول
نقابي
النفاذه اعوان شركه الطرقات السياره
التابعه للدوله
الامين العام للاتحاد نور الدين الطبوبي
اعتبر ان البلاد تعيش حاله احتقان غير
مسبوقه
مشيرا الى ان الرئيس يدعو بطريقه مباشره
وغير مباشره الشعب التونسي الى الاقتتال
وضع دفع المنظمه العماليه الى تنظيم
تحركات خلال الاونه المقبله
ونقرر عددا من التحركات الجهويه
والقطاعيه والوطنيه نعلن عنها في ابنائها
وستكون هيئتنا الاداريه في الاثناء مدعوه
الى انعقاد مع اي طري وقد اثارت تصريحات
الرئيس قيس سعيد داخل تقنه للحرس الوطني
جدلا واسعا في تونس
حيث قال ان العمل النقابي لا يمكن ان
يتحول الى غطاء لمقارب سياسيه
تصريحات قرا فيها بعضهم رساله مباشره وغير
مسبوقه توجه بها سعيد لاتحاد الشغل
واعتبروا انها قد تقود الى صدام بين
الطرفين
المتابعين للشان والكواليس السياسه في
تونس منذ 25 جويليه يعرفون ان هذا الصدام
قادم ربما الا الاتحاد تلعب تنزل الشغل لم
يرد هذه الوصول الى هذه النقطه ولكن ليعرف
شخصيه جمهوريه وشخصيه لن يتراجع في هذه
المعركه مع الاتحاد من الشغل يبقى هل ان
الاتحاد مستعد لهذه المعركه وماذا يملك من
اوراق دعم الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
قرارات سعيد في الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
كان مشروطا باطلاق حوار شامل كما لم يخلو
من انتقادات وصفت باللاذعه في بعض المحطات
لكن الرئيس مدى قدما في خريطه الطريق التي
وضعها
منتجها الاتحاد الى التشاوري مع منظمات
مدنيه فاعله واطلاق مبادره للحوار الوطني
لم يعلن فحواها بعد لكن المستجدات الاخيره
قد تقلص حظوظ تفاعل الرئيس معها
خلاف بين الرئيس قيس سعيد واتحاد الشغل
دفع المنظمه لاتخاذ قرارات وتحركات خلال
الاونه المقبله ما يطرح تساؤلات عن دور
المنظمه مستقبلا وحظوظ نجاح مبادره الحوار
الوطني التي اعلنت سيف الدين الجزيره تونس